wir sind unterwegs in der roten
gefahrenzone an der südfront in der
region nikolai sch es ist eines der
wichtigsten landwirtschaftlichen anbau
gebiete der ukraine vor allem weizen
sonnenblumenkerne und raps werden hier
für den weltmarkt produziert
bis vor kurzem wurde hier noch gekämpft
die russischen bodentruppen konnten
zurückgedrängt werden immer wieder aber
versuchen sie durch zu brechen
regelmäßig wird die region mit
artillerie und raketen beschossen
besonders heftig in den letzten tagen
sie werden begleitet von ober leuten und
oleg zielinsky von der 63 brigade zur
sicherheit an einer behelfsbrücke machen
wir halt der oberleutnant sehen uns
etwas zeigen
dass hier im fluss sind russische grad
raketen über alte ein wasser sind sie
die eigentliche geschichte aber sei wie
diese raketen in den fluss gekommen sind
sie sagt viel aus darüber wie intensiv
die kämpfe nach wie vor auch an der
südfront sind die bauern hier hätten auf
ihre weise zwei russische
munitionstransporter zerstört die defekt
zurückgelassen wurden
sie haben erst messern die reifen
zerstochen und dann die batterien
ausgebaut
als die russen zurückkommen um die
fahrzeuge zu reparieren müssen sie
feststellen dass das nicht mehr möglich
ist und sie jagen ihre eigene nachschub
fahrzeuge samt raketen in die luft damit
sie nicht in ukrainische hände fallen in
einem kleinen dorf hinter der brücke
beginnen wir zu verstehen dass es bei
diesem krieg um sehr viel mehr geht als
um kämpfe zwischen soldaten dass dieser
krieg in der ukraine an mehreren fronten
gekämpft wird auch in der landwirtschaft
auf einem feldweg vor uns ein total
zerstörter traktor wir halten an oleg
unser begleiter von der ukrainischen
armee sagt wir sollten ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein und aufpassen wohin wir
treten der trecker sei auf eine mine
gefahren
die straße ist jetzt sauber aber geht
auf keinen fall neben die straße oder
auch die felder da konnten wir noch
nicht räumen
wir haben zu wenig leute fürs
minensuchen die sind gerade alle vorne
an der front
der treckerfahrer ist umgekommen als er
gleich nachdem die russischen truppen
zurückgedrängt wurden seine felder
bestellen wollte der soldat bewundert
den mut der bauern
ich kann nur sagen er war ein held ich
bin soldat des ukrainischen militärs die
bauern kämpfen an der zweiten front der
wirtschaftlichen damit die welt nicht
hungert front
ein paar kilometer weiter treffen wir
den bauern nominierung ist und er zeigt
uns womit sie hier auf den feldern jeden
tag zu kämpfen haben mitten im rapsfeld
ein bombenkrater ein russisches
kampfflugzeug hat seine felder
bombardiert
sie bombardieren unsere dörfer und
felder wir finden an denen es überhaupt
kein militär
ronny stück zeigt uns ein getreidelager
er habe glück gehabt dass er seine ernte
rechtzeitig in den hafen bringen konnte
bevor die russischen truppen gekommen
sein viele andere bauern die noch unter
russischer besatzung lägen hätten alles
verloren
sie stehen die mähdrescher und
landmaschinen sie stehlen getreide und
saatgut und bringen alles nach russland
und auch gegrillt
wir sind jetzt nicht mehr weit von der
front entfernt 15 20 kilometer sind es
noch im hintergrund immer wieder
kanonendonner die bauern hier war lassen
sich nicht verstecken wir sind
artillerie und raketen angriffe seit
beginn des krieges gewohnt
nach der wahl war manager große farm im
frontgebiet sie produzieren hier
normalerweise 10.000 tonnen
sonnenblumenkernen für die ölproduktion
und ein paar tausend tonnen getreide und
er sieht ganz danach aus als hätten ist
die russischen truppen gezielt auf ihre
farm abgesehen auf dem boden in der
maschinenhalle überall helle weiße
punkte licht das durch die vielen löcher
im dach fällt war das streumunition
ja
viele geschossen
mehrfach wird der große hof getroffen
mähdrescher traktoren sprüh fahrzeuge
vieles sei zerstört und könne derzeit
nicht repariert werden weil sich die
mechaniker der firma aus kiew wegen des
permanenten beschusses hier nicht her
trauen würden
wenn sie hören dass wir aus nikolajew
sind dann wollen sie nicht kommen
in der halle beim altmetall die reste
einer rakete die auf dem hof abgefeuert
wurde nadia verfällt in galgenhumor
das ist unsere ernte
raketen granaten geschosse drohnen viel
davon einfach alles
[Musik]
große teile der farm sind zerstört
nadia das land arbeiter zeigen und
seinen teil ihrer ernte wir fragen hat
er was sie glaubt warum die russen den
farmen wie ihre immer wieder angreifen
würden
als unser gouverneur nach den ersten
angriffen gesagt hat die leute sollten
sich keine sorgen machen die versorgung
sei gesichert
wir hätten genügend getreide in den
lagern und bei den bauern haben wir
festgestellt dass sie die angriffe auf
unsere fahnen und lager verstärkt haben
sie haben gezielt auf die silos
geschossen in denen das meiste getreide
gelagert
erzählt der angriffe aufbauen und farmen
das wären kriegsverbrechen und dann ist
da noch ein anderes problem ein teil der
ernte aus dem vergangenen jahr konnten
sie zwar retten aber jetzt bekäme sie
die ernte nicht mehr los
wir haben viele probleme das größte ist
dass die häfen durch die russen
blockiert sind kein schiff kann die
häfen und die ukrainischen gewässer
verlassen die lager nehmen kein getreide
mehr an sind voll wir können nicht
exportieren und unsere produkte auf dem
weltmarkt verkaufen
mehr als 20 millionen tonnen getreide
und andere agrarprodukte können nicht
ausgeführt werden weil die häfen in
odessa nikolajew durch die russische
marine blockiert werden die blockade und
angriffe aufbauen und ihre farmen uns
wird nach dem besuch bei den front
bauern klar der hunger in der welt wird
für russland zur waffe in diesem krieg
in seinem land dass hunderte millionen
menschen weltweit
grundnahrungsmitteln versorgt
[Musik]